bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
collecter trier recycler depuis deux ans
la gestion des déchets relève de la
compétence de la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines souhaite pérenniser les bonnes
pratiques et ont développé de nouvelles
pour toujours plus de tri pour cela le
territoire compte sur ses habitants
alors comment devenir un bon
gestionnaire du tri on vous dit tout
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
la gestion des déchets revient depuis
janvier 2016 à la communauté
d'agglomération comme le stipule la loi
notre issue de la réforme territoriale
un transfert de compétences qui a
nécessité une toute autre organisation
il y a un an la collecte des déchets
étaient harmonisés au sein des 12
communes et les sept déchetteries
s'ouvrait à tous les habitants du
territoire et depuis donc nous avons
tenté d'uniformiser progressivement
certaines pratiques
en termes de collecte notamment les
communes de maurepas coignières et les
clayes-sous-bois sont passés à la
conteneurisation fini les sacs place au
bac qui l'objet de préparer
progressivement
l'agglomération un contrat unique le
collecte l'idée en fait étant de traiter
l'ensemble des habitants du territoire
de la même manière non plus en fonction
des limites communales mais en fonction
des typologies d'habitat ou des
typologies urbaine
les quartiers mutualisées et optimisées
pour à terme améliorer la qualité du
service et réduire les coûts en 2016 55
mille six cents tonnes d'ordures
ménagères étaient collectées sur le
territoire le but désormais mieux trier
et réduire ainsi le volume pour cela
l'agglomération a mise en place un
service d'ambassadeurs du tri dès 6h du
matin
colette arpentent les rues
saint-quentinoise et vérifie le tri
effectué par chaque habitant
ce jour là l'équipe est à la verrière
quand un référent du secteur à compagne
colette gilet jaune fluo sur le dos
lampe torche et calepin en main notre
ambassadrice inspectent chaque poubelle
alors alors alors alors ça par exemple
c'est l'erreur typique qui est en sac et
ça normalement alors le sac n'est pas
recyclable et ça normalement les
consignes c'est considéré comme un sac
de m
ça normalement la sas a fait participer
des ordres cru après la qualité à
l'intérieur est correct correct en
langage ambassadeur cela signifie
bouteilles en plastique carton et
journaux pour cet habitant ce sera un
code 1 la personne n'a compris les
consignes de tri et n'a pas besoin de
piqûre de rappel
contrairement à un code 2 comme la
poubelle suivante il ya énormément de
plastique quand même faut dire qu on va
dire que c'est super on va dire ça à
corte de b
c'est ses limites code 3 pour un co 2 le
riverain aura droit à un rappel
concernant les bonnes pratiques de tri
plus loin l'équipe tombe sur un code 3
principalement que de l'erreur en fait
beaucoup plus en plus ça y'a du
polystyrène
on peut constater voilà des morceaux de
polystyrène comme ça et ça va
malheureusement le polystyrène plus
toutes les erreurs de tri coup dur
attaque beaucoup suis là je vais être
obligé par exemple de le mettre en cause
trois collègues précise sur la feuille
d'erreurs de tri le pourquoi du refus ce
jour là le camion benne ne collectera
pas le bac
le riverain sera sensibilisé l'après
midi
[Musique]
ben celui-là départ fait la vérification
se termine ce matin là sur une note
positive
[Musique]
l'après midi nous retrouvons ali pour le
porte à porte et les explications
bonjour madame c'est l'agglomération de
saint quentin nous avons parlé aussi de
votre bac de tri bonjour on réalise des
enquêtes localité de matin c'est ma
collègue qui est venu ce matin on me
paie toutes sortes de plastiques mais
dans la plastique pour faire ça si
limitée bouteilles et flacons en
plastique le cul que cette forme là
c'est que ces plastiques uniquement ces
plastiques là chaque jour près de 150
bac sont passés en revue
près de 60 personnes en moyenne
reçoivent qu'une piqûre de rappel à
cause des erreurs de tri c'est vraiment
visuel tout ce qu'on peut mettre et moi
mais je vais l'accrocher surpris au
volant
en cas d'absence de l'habitant le rappel
des bonnes pratiques à dieu malgré tout
alors on va les laisser un avis de
passage qu'on ceci pour leur expliquer
qu'on est bien passé le pourquoi être
catalogué en code 3 et voir sa poubelle
refusé ne fait pas toujours plaisir des
ambassadeurs l'apprennent à leurs dépens
tout ça parce que j'ai mis c'est les
jambes à la le film plastique et autour
des bouteilles de lait des trucs comme
ça
papier toilette et j'avais la mort sont
pas des bulles mais après explications
les choses s'apaisent
tous les produits d'entretien poule aux
oeufs d'or
voilà exactement non madame ayew quelque
chose
8 vinaigre tous cas vraiment une forme
ça qu on fait des consignes de tri
[Musique]
après la collecte
nous voici au centre de tri de 6 dont tu
arrives qui fuit les déchets de
l'agglomération qui seront triés
valoriser petite visite le 6 donc centre
de tri basée à thiverval grignon
c'est ici qu'ils arrivent des déchets
des ordures ménagères qui seront
valorisés mais aussi les déchets triés
relevés dans les poubelles jaunes y 90 %
des déchets sont produits par les
entreprises
les 10% restants proviennent des
citoyens à savoir 10 kg par personne et
par jour pour que ces déchets soient
bien traités ils faut qu'ils soient mis
dans les bonnes poubelles
donc petit cours avec l'expert les
déchets qui se recycle on va y mettre
les aciers c'est-à-dire boîtes de
conserves bidon de sirop les tous les
papiers journaux prospectus magazines
revues cartes ont donc beaucoup de
cartes honnête dans les suremballages
mais aussi les gros cartons marron
alvéolé dans les plastiques les
bouteilles les flacons toujours dans les
plastiques les cubitainer les flacons de
produits ménagers les flacons de
produits toilettes on a les canettes les
l'aluminium les barquettes les aérosols
et les briques alimentaires
d'autant que bien trier ses déchets
auront droit à une seconde vie et nous à
des déchets en moins les plastiques
sombre 10pt foncé seront transformés en
polaire ou en doudou
les plastiques claire dip est haute et
transparent deviendront des peluches ou
d'autres bouteilles plastiques et les
flacons à savoir les pe hd serviront de
conteneurs rigide comme cette arrosoir
ou sept poubelles aussi donc le tri
s'effectue dès l'arrivée du camion benne
ensuite les déchets suivent leur
cheminement jusqu'aux mains des employés
là on retire les erreurs de tri comme
les bâches et sacs plastiques la cadence
empêche toute vigilance les verts ni par
erreur dans les poubelles jaunes
arrivent ici brisé et engendre la
première cause d'arrêts de travail sur
ces tapis en 2017
1805 tonnes de déchets ont été des
erreurs de tri soit 20 % des déchets
pour autant 12 tonnes d'aluminium ont
produit trois mille cinq cents vélos de
104 tonnes d'acier ont été transformés
en voiture 206 tonnes de plastique pet
hd ont donné plus de 1400 bancs publics
5 182 tonnes de pet et à plus de 420
milles couette
les déchets sont alors différencier
emballe les cartons et papiers d'un côté
les briques alimentaires de l'autre une
fois prête les balles seront vendus pour
être transformée de l'argent réinvesti
par les collectivités
et pour finir la visite le musée des
erreurs de tri en 2017 17 déchèteries de
l'agglomération ont été mises en réseau
plus d'harmonisation dans les pratiques
les conditions d'accès et les horaires
et c'est pas fini
les changements se poursuivent au sein
des déchetteries saint-quentinoise à
travers l'arrivée des bennes de déchets
d'equipements d'ameublement six des sept
déchetteries du territoire en sont
désormais équipés ces bennes ont permis
une économie d'environ 700 mille euros
dans le traitement du tout venant autre
changement la signalétique plus clair et
plus visible elle permet une plus grande
autonomie des usagers en 2017 les
déchetteries des clayes-sous-bois et de
magny les hameaux ont été équipés de
nouvelles barrières automatiques et
bornes d'accès rfid pour simplifier
fluidifier et rationaliser les accès
bientôt les déchetteries de maurepas de
guyancourt et d'elancourt devrait en
être également numide et de ce fait fini
le macaron d'accès bientôt chaque usager
pourra se munir de la nouvelle carte
accès en 2017 les déchetteries ont
collecté dix sept mille tonnes de
déchets gravats ferrailles déchets verts
carton ou voix l'harmonisation se
poursuit également du côté de la
collecte avec l'uniformisation du code
couleur le bac jaune pour les papiers
cartons et autres bouteilles en
plastique
le bac gris pour les ordures ménagères
les points d'apport volontaire
continueront à être optimisé nouvelles
bornes et changement des plus vétustes
et l'encours a vu son parc paix avait
doublé en 2010 est le parc de trappes
lui a été entièrement rénové
le futur chantier cette année consistera
à travailler en concertation avec
l'ensemble des villes à la réalisation
d'un cahier des charges commun et
homogène vous savez désormais tout sur
la collecte des déchets bon tri avoue
ciao
[Musique]